so in this video we're gonna talk about
bio acid synthesis and their conjugation
to bile salts and just as a quick note
there are many steps and not all of them
are shown we're just talking about the
basics just a little overview of what's
going on here
so first question is where does this all
happen what's the location well as far
as organs this all happens in the liver
okay
now as far as organelles go some
reactions occur in the ER some of the
mitochondria so in the peroxisome some
also occur in the cytosol we're not
gonna get too hung up on those details
but so you know many organelles are
involved in this process now we saw
previously that bile acids bile salts
they had the steroid nucleus with the
ABC and D rings and they're basically
steroids or steroids and so they come
from the steroid precursor which is
cholesterol so we've got cholesterol
here and that's what we're gonna start
off as far as making bile acids and
eventually conjugating than the bile
salts okay so the the first step in in
producing bile acids is going to be to
convert cholesterol into seven alpha
hydroxy cholesterol and the difference
between these two molecules is simply
this this hydroxyl group is added at
that position that position is the seven
position okay and so we have that
hydroxyl group added and we in order to
do that we need oxygen and and and the
help of NADPH as well to get this to go
and we can see here that these reagents
are reminiscent of what we would use but
with a mixed function oxidase and the
the enzyme that catalyzes reaction is a
mixed function oxidase it's an ER
associated cyp for 50 enzyme
specifically called cholesterol 7 alpha
hydroxylase and that name should make
sense it's acting on cholesterol at the
7 position to give up to add a hydroxyl
group and you'll notice that the
cholesterol there is in parentheses and
the reason why it's in front of the C's
is because it's not always indicated
right sometimes it's just called 7 alpha
hydroxylase okay but cholesterol tells
you that specifically acts on
cholesterol and you'll also notice that
the there's parentheses
with the name seven alpha-hydroxy
cholesterol sometimes it's just called
seven hydroxy cholesterol the Alpha
isn't always mentioned but that because
that refers to stereochemistry and here
I didn't show the stereochemistry
but that enzyme Inoue should make sense
now something to know about this enzyme
is that it's the rate limiting and it
catalyzes the rate limiting step of the
pathway that's the worst start over draw
my life but this is how the rate
limiting reaction okay a rate limiting
step and so if it's the rate limiting
step what does that mean about it it is
regulated okay in fact this enzyme is
stimulated by excess cholesterol all
right so this excess cholesterol
stimulates this and it's at the
transcriptional level right so it makes
that it Trent makes us that that gene is
the gene for that hydroxylase is
transcribed more so we end up having
more of that enzyme and that should make
sense if you if you're familiar with the
fact that excess cholesterol is actually
excreted as as bile salts or bile acids
in the feces so it would make sense that
if there's a bunch of cholesterol around
it would stimulate the production of
bile acids about salt so as to get rid
of that excess cholesterol okay cool now
it's also inhibited by the ultimate
product of what it basically commits to
and that is bile acids so where do we
get those bile acids well let's continue
on with this pathway with seven alpha
hydroxy cholesterol and so we're gonna
have a series of reactions that end up
giving us the D bile acids and these
bile acids are here
Kolak acid and Kino deoxycholic acid and
now they've only got 24 carbons so a few
things happen on the way here and notice
I wrote here many steps they're not all
shown of course but what things happened
well we we reduced we reduced the the
carbon-carbon double bond here that's
gone in in this molecule here and here
and that's no longer there and also
we've shortened the the the sidechain
over here and oxidized it right we know
long
have these 27 carbons we have 24 we have
this carboxylic acid group in these two
bile acids okay so let me get rid of the
numbers there cuz taking a little bit
messy okay but basically those are the
differences between those those
molecules and also in getting Kolak acid
we also had this additional
hydroxylation here so we added this
hydroxyl group to get Kolok acid that
isn't the case in in Kino deoxycholic
acid but what's important recognize is
that these two compounds are bile acids
specifically they are primary bile acids
they are the first bile acids that are
made and they are the product of the
bile acid synthesis pathway which
basically is from from cholesterol for
cholesterol let's just scroll up just a
tad from cholesterol all the way to
these bile acids these primary bile
acids that is basically bile acid
synthesis alright because we made our
bile acids okay and so these bile acids
go back and they can feed back
negatively on this hydroxylase enzyme
that catalyzes the rate limiting step in
their production okay so that's it as
far as bile acid synthesis okay but we
mentioned also that we're gonna make
bile salts through conjugation so what's
happening there so let's scroll down a
little bit to see what's going on here
you